Nick Cordero has died
the Broadway star was 41 years old he
died of complications from the corona
virus following months of
hospitalization for symptoms of kovat 19
Nick is survived by his wife Amanda
klutz and their son Elvis I'm sitting
outside cedars-sinai hospital right now
Amanda kept fans up-to-date about Nick's
ongoing health battle on Instagram this
was one of her posts before his death
next to a black-and-white photo of Nick
and Elvis
Amanda wrote like my dad has said since
day one every day he still with us is a
miracle the triple threat was known for
starring in many Broadway productions
over the years including bullets over
Broadway which earned him a Tony
nomination
[Music]
take nobody's business
[Music]
Amanda first announced Nick's illness on
April first revealing that Nick was
unconscious in the ICU after being
diagnosed with pneumonia the week prior
several days later
amanda revealed that Nick had tested
positive for the corona virus we don't
know what the damage will be not long
after Amanda shared that Nick had his
right leg amputated with doctors citing
circulation and clotting issues that
hadn't been resolved after surgery
Amanda shared updates on Instagram
throughout Nick's hospitalization which
garnered a huge outpouring of love and
support on social media alone this is
Sylvester Stallone she even started the
now popular hashtag wake up Nick Amanda
encouraged family friends and fans to
share uplifting videos of themselves
dancing to Nick's song live your life
[Music]
actor Zach Braff posted several tributes
to Nick on social media he shared this
photo with Nick lin-manuel Miranda and
Leslie Odom jr. he wrote in the caption
quote Nick was my date to Hamilton years
ago I've never seen him so happy
Amanda also shared a touching video of
the couple's first dance at their
wedding she wrote quote I love dancing
with you Nick Cordero and we will dance
again
you